I'm like literally like like sweating
from my hands right now me too this is
like unacceptable
[Music]
hi I'm Rachel I'm Iowa debris and he
my life we are here no just take it
from the top please I'm Rachel I'm IO
debris and we're here with BuzzFeed to
find out how well we actually know each
other the first time we met doing a
sketch doing a sketch on your first job
like ever
I feel like babysitting was like is the
first job
no not mine before babysitting was it in
high school my first job yeah
I just don't think you know it it's okay
do you know mine babysitting
well it was the no mine is technically
something else Gymboree Gymboree
Gymboree baby clothes store yeah I
worked at a nursing home washing dishes
wow wait taking care of the old taking
care of the young we're literally Good
People Meet yours is actually one is a
retail store for children taking care of
the taking care of the young working on
a Gymboree the bottom is chasmber who'd
answer their face time right now Kaya
for me yeah well but right now she's not
in America so I think she's okay but I
would say Kaya I would say Kaya for me
too yeah I feel like Nick would pick up
if you called he would be nervous but he
would be like are you okay are you okay
mate
Nick's an Australian man I can't do
accents I all damn uh oscillating
between British and Australian okay
their least favorite class in high
school
ah you're so smart that I feel like
I want to say math
you also want to say math yeah yeah
you're right you're also right okay cool
favorite bottoms that's so cute jeans
shorts capris Etc
I think for you like a gym short oh yeah
because I feel like you like to like
dress it up or dress it down
I say for you
shorts denim you have the best not denim
but you have the best legs so I want to
say shorts I do like pants but I do love
when Rachel says she loves my legs I
know you literally were changing my
answer first I want to say it's jeans
you wear jeans so well but I love
when you when you show your legs I sound
like a criminal because you are
we got you
yeah I know they're from running it I
rip off I'm that guy I'm that guy that
bill hater always plays in sketches yeah
to catch a red why did I go like that to
get you to catch
I think your heart was in the right
place well your heart was in the right
place I feel like I do wear jeans a lot
yeah I love a big pant yeah oh yeah
you're right their favorite High School
comedy movie
She's the man I don't even like know
what my favorite is but that's
definitely like a favorite saved I want
to say because of the trauma do you love
saved I do like saved a lot but not your
favorite Bring it on Bring It On yeah
they're seen in Bottoms that was the
hardest for them to film without
laughing oh I know Marshawn the scene
where we're looking at Marshall yeah
yeah that was for both of us their
comedy icon
well you said a couple people before
Buster key in people physical comedians
yeah so many of these questions I've
never even asked myself
is what's crazy I feel like I like like
Amy Cher Silverman okay yeah they better
ask me what your karaoke song is because
I know that okay yeah that's true the
first time they made you laugh
I hope I made you laugh in that sketch
but I feel like you just made me laugh
because I feel like you were really
funny in that and I was kind of a
straight Manning so I want to say it
must have been like when I was like
drunk at a party you're incorrect what
is mine it was after the sketch when we
hung out at Hayden oh my God at the
cookies yeah and you were like going on
about the cookies and I was like
something's not right with her she said
she's on wrong love it I'll stick with
her that's my girl that's my girl their
first New York apartment
I would
I live in Katarina and Ari I'm first and
first that was an apartment I thought
that was a dorm I was constantly in
living situations I was trying to hide
from people
okay yeah
okay they're picking it all up yeah it
literally heard me was wearing
everything they're like we have it all
loud and clear and we're writing checks
below your favorite meme the favorite
meme the favorite meme I feel like you
love a meme that's like
Like Girls when like their pastas like
people yeah when they're being their mom
yeah yeah for you
I feel like it's like a dog and it's
like a feeling that the dog is about
that is oh that is like a meme that I
think I really did used to like yeah I
think I'm actually on like finsta or
like sorry yeah that's so real okay no
but it's like it's like a picture of
like a dog and a hat yeah like like it's
covered away do you know the one that
the dog covered in slime yeah I love
that I just love this video this guy
he's just
singing you ever seen a big boy get on a
grill have you ever seen a big boy get
on the grill get on the grill get on the
grill oh my God
we'll link to those
okay I'm done I'm done
10 out of 13 checked you checked more
than 100 of quizmakers
you're the other Chris taker you know
absolutely everything there is to know
about your co-star you've been in each
other's lives for a long time now and
while you're still getting to know them
even better you already feel super close
that's actually true that's true would
you say mine says the exact same thing
as yours but I scored less yeah eight
and you checked more than 50 of this
takers who else is taking this quick
else is taking this quiz get off our
quiz get off our quiz you're not invited
and you don't know what the answers are
I'm Mario
and I am Rachel and thank you for
watching us take this quiz this is not
the outro we were told to do but we
simply have to do one so this is what
it's going to be
you can check out bottoms August 25th in
Select theaters and Nationwide
September 1st goodbye
thank you
[Music]